In this lecture we complete
our discussion of multiple
continuous random variables.
In the first half, we talk
about the conditional
distribution of one random
variable, given
the value of another.
We will see that the mechanics
are essentially the same as in
the discrete case.
Here, we will actually face some
subtle issues, because we
will be conditioning on any
event that has 0 probability.
Nevertheless, all formulas will
still have the form that
one should expect.
And in particular, we will see
natural versions of the total
probability and total
expectation theorems.
We will also define independence
of continuous
random variables, a concept that
has the same intuitive
content as in the
discrete case.
That is, when we have
independent random variables,
the values of some of them do
not cause any revision of our
beliefs about the
remaining ones.
Then, in the second half of the
lecture, we will focus on
the Bayes rule.
This will be the methodological
foundation for
when, later in this course,
we dive into
the subject of inference.
The Bayes rule allows us to
revise our beliefs about a
random variable.
That is, replace an original
probability distribution by a
conditional one, after we
observe the value of some
other random variable.
Depending on whether the random
variables involved are
discrete or continuous, we
will get four different
versions of the Bayes rule.
They all have the same form,
with small differences.
And we will see how to apply
them through some examples.